So, how would you use meta-reasoning to design an agent that can answer Raven's
progressive matrices? Throughout this course we've covered a wide variety of
different methods for addressing this test. And each method has its own
strength and its own weaknesses. Certain methods are better for some problems,
and other methods for other problems. Meta-reasoning will tell us, though,
that you don't have to choose just one. Your agent can have multiple methods to
choose from. Discuss how you might design an agent to have meta-reasoning.
What methods would it have to choose from?
How will it evaluate a new problem and decide what method is best for
that problem? How much improvement do you really expect to see in
your agent's performance based on equipping it with meta-reasoning? And finally,
will your agent engage in any kind of meta-meta-reasoning as we've discussed?
Will it not only think about the methods themselves but also about how it's
selecting a method? And if so, how will that improve it even further?